the indians and the astros tonight sam
hinches the left-hander will get the
start tonight for the tribe as he'll try
to quiet these houston astro bats
took that one and it was right there
good curve ball to strike him out and in
the inning the astros go in order the
indians are coming to bat
lance mccullars jr will face making his
13th start of the season
that was his last start against the
tigers where he beat them going five and
a third throwing 89 pitches and
mccullars deals first pitch is slugged
up the alley right center that'll go to
the wall
and cesar hernandez with a lead off
double to start the party
2-2 to rosario
good
very good pitch and
first out of the game
good pitch
yeah that's that nasty slider
[Applause]
took 27 pitches but the indians leave
them leave the bases loaded lance
mccullers jr strikes out the side
now the 2-2
swing and a miss chase went in the dirt
good curveball pitches
gets his second strikeout correa finally
gets a round of applause now it's chaz
mccormick right fielder hitting 228 291
on base percentage nine homers 27 rbis
the 2-0
and that's hit in the air by mccormick
pretty well out to right center racing
back as ramirez and he'll play that one
off the wall
around third and coming home is toro he
will score and chas mccormick goes into
second base with an rbi double to give
the astros a one-nothing lead astros
with a one-nothing lead is taylor jones
that's with mccormick at second base
got in on him a little bit could be a
tough play
and that drops in for a base hit
mccormick around third chas will score
and for the second straight night a
pop-up to right field falls in and it'll
be a two-base hit for taylor jones
came back and got him
after falling behind in the count
he gets bradley zimmer looking for his
fourth strikeout
[Music]
oscar mercado sends a high fly ball deep
left center straw to the wall can't make
the play
and oscar around second on his way to
third he'll go in with a two out triple
a high fly ball just beyond the reach of
a leaping mile straw
and mercado's 90 feet away with two outs
here in the second
two on one out in the third the astros
leading two nothing two runners on for
correa
there goes brantley again this one
rocking it down the right side
that's a fair ball
extra bases as
altuve will score correa goes into
second base with an rbi double brantley
moves to third and it's three nothing
astros now abraham toro bats correa at
second brantley at third
they're grounded hitches will come home
and
bradley is safe
scoring got started with that guy chaz
mccormick
this one hit hard to left but right at
oscar mercado that'll work get carlos
correa home and a chaz mccormick with
his second run bad end of the night on
the sacrifice fly
castro wheels the bat around a couple of
times he's ready
eighth batter of the inning for houston
the o2 pitch
that one hit into right off that'll be
in for a base hit toro will score at six
nothing houston rbi single jason castro
veronill reyes struck out his first time
up in his first at-bat since being
activated from the injured list and now
he's got his first hit
[Applause]
strike three call
lance with a sixth strikeout of the
night
stefan with the payoff pitch
and strike three called
trevor stefan with his second strikeout
he's retired all three batters that he
has faced
right field and a base in and he's two
for two
that'll send zimmer all the way to third
base
[Applause]
cesar hernandez is at first base that
one got in on him it's gonna be a tough
play correa out taylor jones coming in
that ball hung up better than i thought
it was going to indians leave the bases
loaded for the second time tonight
the two-two pitch swing gonna miss
strength three
stephen retires mccormick and continues
to roll that's seven in a
[Music]
row he did go got him absolutely
[Applause]
got the call
that is the seventh strikeout of the
night for lance mccullars jr might have
been borderline but our match from
supermost shows that bat head gets out
in front of home plate and that's what
triggered that call down at first base
tied him up in a big way and there's
another strikeout there's two away
popped him up
[Applause]
[Music]
through five astros on top six nothing
so mccullers works around the lead off
hit by bradley strands him at first base
we're through five in cleveland
nick whitford punches out altuve to the
delight of this crowd that hasn't had a
lot to cheer about tonight
bullet ride
wow
sometimes you don't have time to get
your feet set
baseball up for him you know we talk
about eye hand coordination all the time
at the plate
get the barrel to the ball but this is
eye hand coordination at its best and
then anticipating a hop
and have that kind of quick hand
reaction to be able to make that play is
pretty good by carlos correa
a couple of buddies picking each other
up right there cesar hernandez
one for two with a double and hit by a
pitch first at bat right-handed tonight
high fly ball deep left field head into
the bleachers swallow it up
cesar hernandez
almost halfway up the bleachers and left
and the indians are back in the ball
game trailing it by a score of six to
three
represents the tying run
here in the seventh inning in a 6-3
ballgame
the one-two
struck him out
got him with the slider again
2-2
right back up the middle but look who's
there
and they will turn a double play
cesar to rosario and back to bradley
[Applause]
for a two-for-one ball here in the
eighth
mercado reached with two outs in the
second with two outs in the fourth
and here he's trying to get aboard to
start an inning and he dies he's safe at
first what a night for mercado
his third head an all-out diving
hustling
effort the 1-1 defran meal
bouncy ball up the middle
correa with the long throw fred mill
beats it out and the bases are loaded
big harold's do he's over three tonight
two balls two strikes two outs swinging
and a miss and he got him and it
indians leave the bases loaded for the
third time tonight
two outs
runner at second
bottom of the ninth inning astros lead
6-3
[Applause]
swing and a miss
that ryan presley comes in and closes
the door